hey guys before we get on with the video
please be aware that there is a lot of
obscure information for the topics of
this video so there's going to be a fair
bit of speculation in the video which
will mostly revolve around those who
live in death the knight of the black
knives godwin himself and the deathbed
companions
background footage will show where i got
the information from so just keep that
in mind and that's it i hope you guys
enjoyed the video back to the story
it happened an age ago
on the night of the black knives
when a fragment of the rune of death was
stolen
a scheme had come to pass
and the first of the demigods fell
the one known as godwin the golden
godwin is the son of queen marika the
eternal and godfrey the first elden lord
when godwin yet limbed he was a famed
dragon hunter for the golden order
he bested the ancient dragon forty sax
but instead of slaying him he befriended
the dragon instead
it was through that friendship that the
ancient dragon cult was created
and through his friendship with dragons
he created incantations for the dragon
cult
which harnessed the very power of
lightning and the power of the dragon
it is also speculated that he was the
favored son of queen marika
and as beloved as he was
his death would be the catalyst that
would cause the shattering
on a wintry night
a fragment of the rune of death was
stolen from malekith the black blade
this fragment was used in a dark ritual
to create knives imbued with the power
of death the instigator for this heresy
was an imperial known as rani the witch
a well-kept secret from the ears of the
golden order
but should you confront rani with this
information she would show no shame in
admitting it
i see
quite the sleuth aren't we
indeed i am the witch ronnie
i stole a fragment of the rune of death
and used it to forge the god slaying
black knights through fearsome right
i did it all
but sadly for thee
the curse mark thou seekest is not to be
found here
i have slain the body i was born into
and cast it away
and it is upon that flesh the curse mark
is carved
and why should i reveal that to thee
i performed the act not to bury the past
nor in shame of the deed
but all the same
thy begging compels me not a jot
the curse mark thou seekest is not here
that is all i will say
now
be gone
although it is unconfirmed if it was
also rani that ordered the murder of
godwin the golden
i do however believe that it was also by
her scheme that god when the golden
perished
for rani needed to circumvent the full
power of the rune of death
by having another demigod die at the
same time as she
for all rani needed to shed was her
imperial flesh to free herself from the
control of the greater will
as such the black knife assassins
entered the capital with their
concealing cloaks and with daggers
infused with death
there they slew the golden god
it is unclear how this power works but
by splitting the hallow brand of death
neither rani nor godwin would be granted
a true death
ronnie would die in body and godwin
would die in seoul
this event would come to be known as the
night of the black knives
before continuing
i understand there are holes in the plot
if the black knives were working for run
but i will address this in a future
video when it comes to run what is of
import here is that ronnie and godwin
had died at the same time but in
different ways
but despite godwin's soul being killed
by the hollow brand of death his body
did not die with it
as such he did not get a true death
the golden epitaph was created to
commemorate his death
it is a sword infused with the humble
prayer of a young boy
likely to be mikola the unalloyed as the
symbol of the heilig tree is shown when
invoking the prayer
the prayer goes as follows
oh brother lord brother
please die a true death
but what does it mean to have a true
death
in the age of the earth tree death does
not exist
for you see the elden ring governs the
laws of the lands between
and it can be freely altered depending
on what runes are contained within the
elden ring queen america the eternal had
removed the rune of death
as such
the law of death did not exist within
the lands between
so how does one receive a true death
well
in order to answer that
we must look to those who live in death
creatures of undead
whose souls are rejected by the earth
tree
as such
they remain in a state of undead
their bodies decay and wrought and yet
they live in suffering
when you visit certain catacombs with
those who live in death within
you might find some death root
these are fragments of the rune that
scattered through the earth tree's roots
when godwin had perished
these death roots do not truly impede
the souls of the dead
but rather they hearken unto the bodies
of the dead
allowing them to rise once more
the souls themselves are rejected by the
earth tree
but they believe that it is only a
matter of time until they are hewn into
the tree
and thus the souls are patient
until the moment the death root caused
them to live once again
this was actually a revelation learned
by roger and he shared this information
with
do you us of those who live in death
the very notion of life in death defies
the golden order by dee's account these
defiled fiends must be expunged but
truth be told
i seek the curse mark to save them you
may find this peculiar but i discovered
something in my examination of the night
of the black knives
these souls have committed no offense
they have every right to life only they
happen to touch upon a flaw in the order
those who live in death are souls who
have committed no offense
against the golden order according to
roger they have every right to life
but they are denied such a right because
they happen to touch upon a flaw in the
golden order
what flaw this is though is simply
unknown
as such they are denied a true death
a true death means death in body and
soul
the body fades into runes and the soul
is hewn into the earth tree
only then can a peaceful true death be
attained
the other way would be to destroy the
soul and the body with the sacred rites
of the golden order
no longer allowing the soul to be
reincarnated into new life
godwin's soul was never hewn into the
earth tree and so his demigod body can
never die his soul was not destroyed by
any litany of proper death though
as such
he can still be revived by a deathbed
companion
his body though is but a husk what truly
contains his soul is the hollow brand of
the death prince
which is split in two
but as the first demigod to die
his body is mutated into the prince of
death
and he is the first demigod for those
who live in death
the deathbed companions are tarnished
from a place beyond the lands between
these maidens would attain the vigor of
champions by staying by their side on
their death
preventing their soul from being hewn
into the earth tree and once enough
vigor has been attained they would lay
with an exalted noble and give them new
life
this is an affront to the golden order
fia the deathbed companion was one such
maiden
she was exiled from her home for
possessing the guidance of grace
for those who live in death are directly
opposed to the golden order as such
one who receives their grace is
unwelcome in their home
this was not what fia wanted
fia was proud for her position as a
deathbed companion
despite her hatred for the guidance
however
this would bring her to the foot of the
most exalted one
godwin
the prince of death
one who will be able to restore the
order of death and mend the fragmented
elden ring
with the mending rune of the death
prince
[Music]
if you recall earlier i mentioned the
hollow brand of death was split in half
one half is with ronnie who used it on
herself in order to break free from her
imperial flesh
and the other surprisingly was with
darion
or better known as d
let me take this chance to talk a little
bit about dee
he and his brothers are hunters of the
dead within the golden order
they are inseparable twins who found
solace within the order who did not
revile them as accursed beings for they
only have one soul
but share two bodies
when one body is active the other is
asleep
which is why when dee dies his brother
wakes
and knows what happened and if you ever
visit his brother while dee lives you
will find him in a deathless sleep
in any case going back to the hollow
brand
dee was in possession of the hologram
that killed godwin
probably found by his brother as he was
one who came face to face with the
prince of death
due to this fia had come to the round
table hold in order to kill dee
and retrieve the hollow brand
you might ask how did fian know that d
had the holobrand
well
rajer came to side with those who live
in death
after he found out the revelation we
spoke of earlier
unbeknownst to d
rajer regularly lays with fia as well
it was rajir that told fia of the hollow
brand but it was also thanks to fia that
roger knew of the location of these
brother
these brother had come into contact with
the prince of death and i believe it was
rajir who gave the dagger to fia
the dagger that bore a curse of death
it was this dagger that we gave thee
that would ultimately kill darion
allowing fia to retrieve the hollow
brand of death
and finally renounce the round table to
join her prince
another interesting thing when you think
about it
isn't it strange that dee didn't know
about fia being associated with those
who live in death
well
i think he didn't even know fear was in
the round table hold
you see the bed chamber where fear
resides is not truly just a bed chamber
when she occupies it
but it is a hidden temple for those who
live in death
the baldicon's blessing that we receive
from fia is a blessing of a temple
hidden as a bed chamber which numbs our
sensations to bring us closer to death
increasing our poise and granting damage
negation in exchange for five percent of
our max hp
a small price to pay for a nice hug
the other half of the hallow brand was
still within the discarded flesh of
ronnie the witch
which we find out thanks to rajeer and
we can retrieve it after helping ronnie
unfortunately roger dies before we can
show him the other half of the holobrand
[Music]
the next time we find fia we find her
with godwin's grotesque form at the
roots of the earth tree
the body has been twisted beyond
imagination
no longer resembling godwin in the
slightest and we see the curse of death
in the death room emanating from the
wound of the hollow brand
and at the foot of the prince's throne
we find fear
before we can even approach her we have
to fight her champions with two notable
appearances
roger who allied with fiat the round
table hold
and lionel who passed away in the
capital city at the side of another
deathbed companion
lionel had come across fia before and
swore to protect her as her father
after we defeat them we come face to
face with fia who asks if we are here to
stop her and if we still believe in the
vision of the golden order
if we say yes
then she tells us that we have to kill
her
but if we say no and instead hold her
tight she will find this peculiar
here we can give her the other side of
the hollow brand and she is surprised
but thankful
she gives us a tighter hug and gives her
most precious gift
a gift a deathbed companion can only
give once in their life
finally with the holobrand complete
fia can now lay with godwin and give him
new life
as an exalted demigod though this new
life is not as simple as a rebirth
but rather a new rune for the elden ring
a rune that will restore death within
the lands between
fia asks that once she lays with godwin
that we are to receive the rune and
become elden lord
however things are never that simple
after we return to her once she lays
with godwin we find that the rune is not
born and she is unconscious next to the
prince
we are able to enter the death bed dream
at this point
only to find one last obstacle that bars
the restoration of death
the lich dragon 40 sacks
remember godwin had befriended this
ancient dragon in his youth and this
dragon had been within godwin the entire
time
fighting the death curse from within
but the dragon itself was corrupted by
the power of death
and turned into a lich dragon
the dragon prevents godwin's foul
rebirth and so we must lay it alone
a mere dragon of course is no match for
the tarnish
as such
once we return from the dream
we finally find the mending room of the
death prince
contrary to appearance fia is not dead
at this moment only asleep
once we leave and return
we will find these brother
too late to prevent the ruined birth but
he gives a powerful speech anyway
see the wrath of the golden order the
orders justice writ in blood
this is what's become of your precious
witch
naught but expired meat and bone
this is a proper death oh prince
look at this rotten hall
no more children can be got from this
useless flesh
behold
your mother is dead
[Laughter]
this is revenge you witch and you you
cool
this is the wrath of
hello
the rotten witch is dead
the golden order unsullied
now i can look my brother darion in the
eye
honeyed rays of gold
deliver my spirit
darion
now i have no regrets
honeyed rays of gold
deliver my spirit
you can choose to kill him or not either
way he leaves after avenging his brother
you must now become elden lord an
adamanting room to the elden ring to
restore death within the lands between
or
you can uphold the golden order
grant nicholas prayer
forsake the rune of the death prince
allow godwin his true death
and return to our home
bathe
in honeyed rays of gold
[Music]
you